okay let's go ahead and get started
today we're doing a thesis defense and
most of you know the drill but exit
before we do that a couple announcements
and this is the last time you'll hear
this from me but next Wednesday night
there's a great movie and I know a lot
of many if not most of you are signed up
Kevin Johnson who's the chair of
biomedical informatics at Vanderbilt and
he's XE on Thursday talking in this
conference and then meeting with the
fellows and it's just kind of open it's
something that I always enjoy doing when
I go to other places and we can talk a
little bit before then but if you guys
however you guys want to organize either
present some of your ideas to him to get
his feedback ask him if he's hiring etc
okay then one other event i'm going to
start mentioning is on friday october 28
is the celebration of the 25th
anniversary of the BIC building and we
have tentatively lined up and she has
tentatively agreed pending her starting
her new job the other email you got from
me yesterday ax that dr. patty Brennan
has been named the director of the
National Library medicine which i think
is good I think most people think is
good and anyways we had always intended
to invite the new director to that and
after i sent my congrats ettore email i
said by the way i'm inviting you to come
visit ohsu on october twenty eighth and
she will be coming well she tentatively
said she will be coming she actually
didn't start the job until August
although those of you going to the NLM
meeting will get to meet her in June in
Columbus I'm trying can't remember the
last time she was here but she's very
high presence at a Mia
of you already know her she's a really
great person a great choice for the job
and also at the event on the
twenty-eighth will be dr. Don Lindbergh
the former director for 30 years he will
be here too and a bunch of others so it
should be a fun day and there will
probably be opportunities for you guys
to put up posters or something like that
we're still planning the day anyway so
let's move on to our session today as I
mentioned it's a master's thesis
proposal so many of you have been
through that where the process is that
we go through the the student who's
defending his or her thesis gives a
presentation there's then public
questions so anyone in audience can
participate then we all leave leaving
behind just the committee or whoever's
here of the committee and then they can
ask him further questions then he's
dismissed and they decide whether or not
he passes and if he passes he's done
although he's not totally done he still
actually needs to write up his thesis
even if he are you marching in the
graduation war there okay okay yeah
because sometimes people march in the
graduation usually at the anticipation
that they've actually completed
everything but anyways so I don't want
to take too much events time but let me
just introduce him briefly he received
his bachelor's degree in psychology with
an emphasis in neuropsychology and minor
political science from Whittier College
after graduating worked as a research
technician at university California
Irvine in aspects of neuro science and
he then like many of you left the wet
lab or dryer pursuits and did a number
of things including web applications and
data visualizations and ended up here
and so he has been
suing the master's degree and today
we're going to hear the results of his
work so take it away
I'm sorry before your prayer I goofed I
am I thought you were actually defending
your know is you're defending your
proposal gotcha that's correct with
opposable see if this okay so to begin
all in sorry it's can loan I'll begin by
introducing my topic in discussing the
mutational landscape of cancer and
specifically the variance of interest to
this research how we detect them and the
sample properties that influence their
detection from there I'm going to
provide a background on the problem
space and how we model background error
in sequencing data and i'll be
discussing the specifics of frequently
encountered types of background air
current approaches we use to modeling it
and then discuss my research question
the hypothesis from there i'll introduce
my specific aims the methods i plan on
using the data will be working with and
the potential impact of this research
finally by a Q&A old bike unit so as
many of you undoubtedly know parents
come in a wide variety of physical
structures which are visible through the
comparison of a sample or a sequence
ture reference genome and some of the
most basic types of variants are the
single nucleotide variants insertions
deletions mutations and in addition to
these we have the longer substitutions
deletions insertions inversions
duplications needs in this slider kind
of described as just structural variants
and of course well not explicitly
pictured here we also have chromosomal
variants which are similar and can
infect the chromosome or an entire
online chromosome for the purpose of
this research I'm going to be focusing
solely on single new
so in addition to the structural
distinction they come in two forms
somatic and germ line and to the right
we see germline variants and these are
rise from germ cells and are often
discussed in the context of the
heritability from a parent individual to
an offspring generally speaking when
these variants are inherited they are
present in all in DNA of all the cells
of the body in contrast somatic variants
which are to the left differ in that
they arise spontaneously within the
cells throughout the lifestyle lifetime
and these are the mutations that are all
more often associated with cancer among
other disorders that are kind of
resulting from tissue-specific
dysregulation throughout this
presentation when I talk about parents
I'm only going to be really referring to
the somatic variants otherwise I'll
specify that I'm talking about your germ
line
there we go so for single nucleotide
variants their detection comes down to
allele frequency which in this context
can be described as the proportion of a
population of cells in a sample that
exhibit a given variant allele so in
this kind of abstract representation we
see oly we c allele frequencies on the y
axis and we see the physical base
position on the x axis and i'll note
that these are not genomic coordinates
so if we break these out by kind of
their diet IDEs and imagine that we've
been charged with the confident
detection of single nucleotide variants
using this graph and only our eyes we
might pick out these four alleles on the
left and then we've report that we
detected for single nucleotide variants
in the target sequence and the rationale
behind this choice may be that the data
points on the graph these are probably
variants and we picked them because they
appear to have a significant deviation
from the background variation in allele
frequency and we may argue that this
deviation indicates that there is in
fact a proportion of cells in the
sequence population that truly exhibits
these variants but if we look closer we
can also discern that there looks to be
some background error and noise and that
is representative there and then when we
kind of see the background arrow noise
you say okay well there's also this
region here and maybe we'll call that a
low confidence region that's an area
where there seems to be a significant
deviation but we can't really discern
whether its meaning for not and so when
we consider that we may say okay well
then this is our high confidence
threshold above here we we can be
confident in the detection of bearing
below we're not actually so sure so when
we keep this in mind and we're
discussing our power to detect variants
from sequencing data we're often
referring to minor allele frequency
simply put minor allele frequency is the
frequency at which the least common
allele occurs in a population of
interest so for the example of visually
detecting variance using this figure we
may say for simplicity that our
detection limit is about point 14 or
one-point-four percent naf meaning that
we can detect with high confidence and
the alleles present in that population
existing at a frequency higher than 1.4
percent so of course if detecting
variants was that simple his
presentation probably wouldn't be
happening allele frequency is heavily
influenced by a number of sample
properties which include purity
clonality and copy number the major
sources and these are major sources of
confounding in a sample when these
Domanick scommn bine the frequencies of
variant alleles in a sample are quickly
confounded and often reduced making
their comment and detection difficult so
from this research I'll primarily be
focusing on purity and clone allottee
copy numbers a little hard to get
traction on and probably would be more
for a dissertation now before getting
into the specifics of sample purity I
should emphasize that whenever we
sequence a biological sample more often
than not and I kind of hinted at this
earlier we're sequencing a population of
cells this is a critical point because
the cell population contains variant
subpopulations and when we sequence the
population of that sample the proportion
of sequence reads that exhibit now we're
the only participate in the conference
please press any key on your keypad to
remain in conference
so the the proportion of sequence reads
that exhibit this variant should be
roughly proportion or equivalent to the
allele frequency in the entire
population and this is kind of the ideal
scenario so that said when we have here
we have an abstract representation of a
blood vessel the peripheral blood and if
we draw blood and sample it we're going
to be getting a sample of that
population and it's important to note
that we're going to get normal cells in
there too which reduces the purity of
the sample and also reduces the allele
frequencies and this can be kind of a
confounder so before assessing and
calling variants this is something
missing oh well only in the kind of
thing all right so so yeah this reduced
sample purity is evident confounder that
we really need to account for in any
modeling of error so in addition to
purity there's also tumor clonality and
this is kind of a handful the idea is
that among a tumor there's heterogeneous
clonal populations with multiple
genetically distinct subclones and these
subclones can each house different
behaviors and exhibit different
characteristics that kind of when you
combine them attribute or generate the
phenotypic characteristics of a given
cancer to understand how clonality
develops it helps to first understand
how cancer develops the first step on
the path to cancer is the initialization
of all kind of genesis with an initial
driver mutation after this
initialization we also often see a
clonal expansion where malignant cells
with the initial driver mutation pick up
additional mutations so at this point it
we're in a sequence the sample of a
sample of this malignancy we would see
multiple subclones likely with a common
driver mutation
and different variable variant allele
frequencies for other mutations and
maybe this would be the time that you
would get diagnosed and start your first
round of treatment of course as we all
know oftentimes treatment isn't
completely effective and while the
population of subclones may be reduced
significantly we'll probably have also
selected for the resistant subclones in
this population and this is really
classic population genetics look at this
point if we assume a treatment response
the variant allele frequencies will have
been reduced due to this reduction
malignant cells but we'll also had that
population shifted now if we imagine
that because of these surviving
subclones me were to relapse once again
we may choose to receive another round
of treatment and we'll see a similar
similar situation potentially where
disease burden and variant allele
frequency is reduced from the treatment
but we're also getting a selection of
these milligan subclones and getting a
shift in clonal structure in the
population structure so in the context
of detecting cancer cells and signaling
to you when you buy their single
nucleotide variant markers the challenge
really increases with treatment success
which is a little bit ironic I mean the
further challenges in sorry further
challenges in the analysis these
variants are also compounded by the 15
construction population so altogether in
the narrow context of single nucleotide
variants the mutational landscape of
cancer exhibits a significant level base
complexity and this really comes down in
this case to the purity of the sample
and restructure the clonal dynamics of
the population
so max I'll be covering some background
shifting gears the way we detect these
variances through complex computational
pipelines that apply a statistical
framework using these pipelines in
next-generation sequencing the power to
detect variance is largely contended
contingent on the read depth of the data
that said sequence coverage also plays a
significant role because if we can't we
kind of missed the Baron entirely we're
not going to find it so if we keep this
in mind we can approach the problem in a
statistical framework as such with a
lack of coverage which we see on the
bottom we're just going to miss our
variance if we have correct coverage but
inadequate debt we're going to detect
variants we're not going to necessarily
very confident in them and we also may
discard variants for background area now
if we are adequately powered and a half
coverage will be getting high confidence
variants and will also be separating out
the platform error but we'll still have
these low conference variants and those
are the ones were really interested in
so you know and it should be noted that
currently studies really are sitting up
on top we you know we do have adequate
debt and coverage is really down to
experimental design know if the
experimental designed it for that's when
coverage will finish so at present the
dominant pipelines for variant calling
our gatk or the genome analysis toolkit
mutex which are both from the Broad
Institute and gatk focuses on germline
variants while mutex focuses on somatic
variants and these pipelines are often
used in conjunction with Illumina
sequencing technology and gatk in
particular has seen a lot of success in
genome-wide Association studies so as I
mentioned across major pipelines there
is the suspect in the case of the
missing variants is likely hiding in the
pre-processing step
which is which hair would mean the eqs r
which is the background error model or
gatk detect and the way be q sr works is
it kind of takes in a lot of platform
error and machine specific contexts and
it uses that to update quality scores on
the actual sequence so that the
downstream variant caller can have
better data to work with and call these
variants more effectively and of course
you know what is a quality score well
it's if you imagine that along each base
we're performing a hypothesis test the
quality score is going to be kind of
like a p-value it's going to give us a
level of understanding of how confident
we can be in a given base call so
relevant to this research there are a
number of potential weaknesses in some
of these error models not just beat us
are in the context of calling low
frequency variants should we notice
noted that a lot of these pipelines were
established to build high confidence
around variants and not surface low
confidence variants so I'll touch on
these in a bit but so before I
so that's badass so the first error is
GC content bias and this refers to an
increase in GC DNA base content if we
look at the figure here we see that GC
content Co very significantly with
sequins coverage on the y axis we have
the coverage along a sequence by
x axis so as we can see as coverage
decreases we observe significant bias
towards genes
we also see that coverage is hetero
genes
having coverage below 6,000 this
additional heterogeneity can complicate
the assessment
addition to that we also have home of
homes group homes relate to repeating
basic
machines
troubled regions and we can see that
they having trouble when we find
reference and see that
slide we see that base insertions
deletions
and in fact we also see the same for
color saturation
and
and so maybe the simple solution let's
do research
library of these profiles for each of
these technologies and their their
species but that would quickly generate
pretty complex library and it's not
really a scalable solution so what
research is focused
you know they used distributions and
comparable distributions no leverage to
the observed data
and these distributions may not be ideal
because they exhibit significant bias or
have the potential to
towards the available data and I'm not
necessarily bad these distributions can
make reducibility and cross model
comparisons a little more challenging
theoretical distributions on the other
hand these are distribution such as
governing the distributions but these
are the ones we making most of all
acquainted with more statistics classes
and these are a little more robust to
analysis and have much better understood
assumptions and with these understand
understanding
so in addition to these distributions
background error models also frequently
used threshold and this is done to
distinguish distinguish signals of
interest from background there these
specials generally come in two flavors
and there are global thresholds and
these essentially are similar to a
statistical test in the case of
qualities
so if you
sequence we would essentially accept
basis as being significant when they
kind of reach the tail under the
distribution at a threshold is set in
contrast when we look at local
distributions what we're trying to do is
really use sequence specific context as
we move across the distribution to
better inform how we're calling these
kind of detecting these true signals and
so we may use a sliding window to
approach or a k-mer approach or just use
an entire read and if we imagine that
you know the distributions moving along
we could also see it kind of shifting up
and down and that really is kind of the
key to this
so in addition to distributions and
thresholds one of the common techniques
we see to is clustering and generally
speaking the common goal clustering is
to generate an air lock in air moles is
to generate sets or clusters and trusted
sequences reads using some heuristic and
once we have a trusted set we can take
the less trusted sequences and kind of
correcting towards these trusted
sequences also using an artistic
approach for the first on the left the K
more spectrum approach we often cluster
by and edit this measure and that's
usually something like having distance
which is the minimum number of changes
that can be made to sequence
considering in without considering
insertions and deletions or the
levenshtein distance which is similar
but does consider in the insertions and
deletions another approach which we see
to the right is to cluster based on a
k-mer frequency and this assumes that
the more frequent of camer is the more
Rican trusted and of course with a k of
three this wouldn't be very informative
and so usually k will be much larger and
that kind of gets to how do we choose K
and little out of scope but it's kind of
its own art form so another approach
very similar to clustering is to use
graph models and we would cluster by
frequency in student and these are very
similar clustering by frequency and they
construct camer graphs which are a
common approach taken by sequence
assembly software to do error correction
during the assembly process one example
here is Debray graphs and in graph
theory de Bruyne gas or n dimensional
directed graphs but the set of symbols
and that overlap 11
so what does that mean in the context of
error correction AK value is selected to
break sequences in overlapping k more
nodes and where the came where the
overlaps represented the edges of the de
Bruyne grab from this sequence assembly
software is able to assemble the reeds
into a consensus sequence which we often
call can take and sequences that and
correct sequences that are poor matches
to their closest camer while de Bruyne
graphs are just one example there are
actually many other graphing techniques
that are also used across error models
and so in considering these varied
approaches it's helped helpful to kind
of you know use them as kind of features
to break down these error models and
kind of understand what error models are
using currently here I've done just that
for a very small subset of these models
and these models are not necessarily
standalone they may be found an existing
software from this we see that the
landscape with each method you know it's
very diverse and each of these models
has its merits and may have its
drawbacks too which often surround the
context for its use we see empirical
thresholds and theoretical thresholds
and you know down here we see a
combination of the two and this is
really kind of leveraging the power of
boat similarly we also see our sorry
that was distributions we also see
different global and local
and locals can be based on haplotypes
windows and oftentimes combining these
who can get a better estimation
variation they also use very different
correction methods some use camera
frequencies and clustering others use
kind of mixture models and others use
expect asian maximization so there's a
lot of different approaches here and
each kind of have their own perks and
potential drawbacks and of course the
errors accounted for aren't necessarily
all the same some really focus on
detecting GC content and correct
so with that my research question is is
our power to detect low-frequency
variation being reduced by current
background air modes and with that kind
of terms of the hypothesis which is that
we can improve the detection of low
creep low frequency variants
significantly through the development of
a novel background error mole that is
actually optimized for the specific
context and we're that my first aim will
be to create a framework that evaluates
turn background our models and leverages
these evaluations for the development of
an enhanced or novel background error
model that it is designed specifically
for this use case and then the second
one will be to apply the final
background arimo to the task of
detecting residual disease in leukemia
which is a particularly challenging kind
of abuse case in the great kind of
motivational example
so the evaluation framework will seek to
evaluate the error models using GG 80km
youtek as the test bed and their
application too and they'll be applied
to detect low-frequency variants under
multiple conditions the first condition
will be to run gatk mutex just without
beak us are the back their native
background air mobile and this will be
to kind of establish your case it's be
threats are actually helping us detect
these low frequency variants and from
there will iterate through and
essentially adapt additional error moles
into this pipeline not necessarily in
place of the dress or the other most
rational point in the pipeline and
gather statistics and try and really
understand how these error moles are
performing and once we've got these
statistics we can use them to kind of
rank
so performance is going to be assessed
in pretty standard sensitivity
specificity precision and accuracy and
he's really got seeking actually going
to
hopefully also so in addition to the
standard also be using precision recall
curves to visually assess the trade-off
interest
this will be a nice
the first set of data i'll be using is
whole genome sequencing synthetic data
generated by the ICGC TCGA and this data
is essentially real human data that has
been heavily modified so we have no
bearing in the data
and they also
it is lower depth than what we are
interested in but to account for that
we'll also be doing fixed dilution
series or the night diagnostic lab will
be doing one and this will take normal
and tumor sample pairs and the tumor
samples generated from will be generated
with eighty to ninety percent purity and
variable allele frequencies and this
will essentially be unknown truth set to
that's more more relevant to the
application we're actually seeking to
apply this model to these samples will
be sequenced using a 43 gene leukemia
panel that's used at ohsu and or
previously was used at ohsu and this was
done on the Ion Torrent PGM platform and
the specifics of this data are still
being discussed as you probably can see
from the slide so for my second aim I'll
be seeking to apply this novel
background airmall to the challenge of
detecting minimum residual disease and
so you may be wondering what is minimum
residual disease minimal residual
disease is defined as the post therapy
disease burden and this is particularly
considered in the space of cancer and
hematologic malignancies so minimum
residual disease kind of a null
background on what they can do for us
they provide really valuable feedback
tone cultists allow them the opportunity
to kind of track disease and therapy
progression and in certain cases they
can predict relapse pursue a more agile
treatment plan and avoid unnecessary
drug toxicity or not oppo attic stem
cell transplants altogether these
advantages can translate into really
meaningful
so if we consider this
unfortunately given the nature of
success when treating which I noted when
we were discussing clonality monitoring
minimal residual disease gets more
challenging as our treatment progresses
and those clonal populations kind of
contract and lose their frequency so
while it goes without saying that zero
detectable energy is what we want this
is kind of a great wave or this is a
good way to really assess when we get to
those lower frequencies can we actually
detect and speaking of detection in the
clinic detection limits can actually
very and our concept of clinical
complete remission can also be a little
bit variable too and it really comes
down to the methods we're using as we
can see from this graph detection limits
vary by these methods you can see one in
every 1,000 cells roughly for microscopy
and fish down to one in a million
roughly for next-generation sequencing
and as we kind of push this detection
limit down we can better assess whether
you know relapse is a real potential or
is very unlikely so altogether by
pursuing this use case of minimum
residual disease the same will really
serve to both validate the model and to
do it in a real world using real-world
data in a clinically meaningful way and
to a very relevant so the data for this
aim is 3210 samples from 698 patients
here at ohsu and of these patients 236
have to or greater samples or a minimum
residual disease assays so this means
that we could potentially kind of take a
posterior distribution of variants that
we picked up from the first to say and
use that to inform our calling in the
second in the second to say
the samples exhibit variable cellularity
and of the 43 only 41 genes or presence
and the sample source is from peripheral
blood and bone marrow aspirate similar
to the fixed I Lucien series they've
been sequence on the Ion Torrent PGM
platforms using a 43 gene leukemia panel
and the mead meet depth is roughly 16 51
which is pretty good this this should
give us enough power to detect down to
down to a good minor allele frequency so
it's the impact the validation of
current background air moles a one
should provide a meaningful contribution
to the understanding of awful background
error models for low frequency variant
calling using gatk and detect and frame
to this project will serve to improve
the sensitivity and specificity of mr d
essays by the kdl or the night
diagnostic lab and unlock further
potential for agile treatment and
improve patient outcomes in addition to
the development of the novel background
error model designed for the detection
of low-frequency variants which may be
innovative developing the core tenants
have generalized built developing this
model with the core tenets of
generalizability and extensibility it
should have the potential to augment our
ability to detect similarly x similarly
subtle biological signals across a more
broad area of research interests and
this could ultimately yield a lot of
benefits to the field of just generally
detecting their biological variation so
with that I'd like to thank everyone my
committee and Suzanne for help the night
I lost lab for doing these fixed
citations and feedback Leukemia and
Lymphoma Society which will be funding
some of this research Diane doctor
couldn't have done this without you and
of course my cohort and the department
appreciate very much thank you and
questions
yes
so much of this i didn't understand what
it looked great so the question I'm
going to throw out use a bit of a
curveball perhaps so what are the
ethical implications of detecting
minimal residual disease at smaller and
smaller levels in terms of impact on
patients and healthcare systems yeah I
think you know I think that's a great
question you know it's so it kind of
gets down to I would say well i would
say that there's definitely some ethical
implications of how you provide
treatment to patients whether these
essays can actually give them the
treatment they need and actually
influence what treatments they get and
kind of in how we ration care to these
patients I think that you know it's
definitely I haven't really quite
thought out all the ethical issues
personally so it's definitely something
I need to look into more but I'm sure
you know in medicine we're fraught with
that issue quite frequently so I'm sure
there are some that should be considered
very seriously thanks so you said the
the current background model that
they're using something with a Q forget
you can be q sr um so what it basically
does is correct the base error score and
then you said that you'd we're going to
look at different models in possibly
different places in the pipeline where
that would change so we're also in the
pipeline do you think that you you could
introduce an error model or is
correcting backgrounds you know bass
scores of like what are the pros and
cons of doing that or some other way so
some of our models we've been looking at
are actually kind of coming from
research into a viral population
dynamics and so eqs are is really you
know it's already done the alignment
it's it's essentially updates the
quality scores so that downstream the
variant caller can do a better job on
some of these our models could be put
ahead of it too sorry so those are
alignment quality scores of the base
quality scores that come off of the
sequencer I believe those are aligned
the qualities yeah so it's it's already
been aligned so if we if we kind of look
upstream we some of these error models
are actually could be used to kind of
bet do essentially better evaluation of
the quality of the sequence before we
align and I think really the whole point
of that was to say that while be q sr is
one approach using quality scores a lot
of these approaches don't actually do it
take quality sport so kind of taking
where where is the best place to put
this where are we kind of you know
violate the fewest assumptions and
what's really should it be use with us
or should it not one of their models
that I presented low freq actually
encourages the use of b q sr alongside
it so it's not necessarily an or it's
really you know seeking a combination of
em all so I could work that answer
question I think it's obviously pretty
complicated and there's probably a lot
of different places in the pipeline that
you could think to try to improve but
yeah i just also just wanted some
clarity on where exactly they were doing
this background correction to its own
it's after alignment but you know before
very Nicole other questions
right
yeah hold it down huh I'm probably the
only non violent format assist in the
room but I guess my question is how are
you going to what tools are going to use
to assess the various background
subtraction methods as to optima bility
or whatever word I want to use how do
you know which ones outperform the
others what's a criteria will you use
yeah so I think that that kind of gets
to mean if I'm understanding your
question correctly I think that's going
to be really getting towards a
sensitivity and specificity and kind of
when we when we run we run the data
through GV and we run it without the eqs
are you run it with eqs are say we take
you know Model X and we insert it at the
most logical point we're essentially
going to look from the baseline of no
error model at all no beat us or
anything and kind of look at how the
variant calls in the truth set match up
and kind of use sensitivity and
specificity to see how those align
together yeah does that answer your
question so long it does that I guess
the key question being do you have a
truth set I mean that's what's key is
that that's what you're going to apply
it to so yeah I mean you know I think
the fixed dilution series they'll be a
true set there and I think that also
with the the ICGC TCGA dream challenge
data because it's synthetic we have a
train set we have known known sample
pyridine
variant allele frequencies so with Mr D
I guess di think we also discussed the
identified patient reports potentially
inside of genetics and that those could
also offer a truth set there with the
dream data how far how rare are the
rarest allele frequencies you know like
feathering rare I think eighteen percent
once you you know account for the purity
and how that influences the very little
frequencies I think the low as it gets
down to is about eighteen percent it's
going to be basically sippy you work on
that first and be able to detect all
those at eighteen percent frequency yeah
right you won't really know if you can
do better than that things that are at
lower frequency than that and maybe with
the dilution series you'd be able to get
at that because if you detect something
with a really low or low dilution I
guess so there's a lot of reeds there
and you can see again if you can detect
it when it's much more diluted later
yeah and I think the reason the the
reason the TCGA you know the synthetic
data the reason it's quite high in pure
or variant allele frequencies is because
this is whole genome sequencing data so
it's got lower depth and so our power to
detect these is going to be a little bit
more compromised when we compare it to
the target panel which is what the fixed
dilation series is going to be so these
are two kind of different platforms that
we're going to be using and we're going
to really see if any models we develop
can be used to detect these in both
settings i guess i was looking for you
about that too sorry for all the
question so in the targeted panel you're
only sequencing certain genes and
there's some targeted pull down of those
jeans yeah so it's a 43 gene looking
which we've been using her is really now
my is it 76 yeah this is historical good
okay so you have you have something that
pulls down just those sequences based on
primers that are aligned to those known
sequences and
yeah I think that would be honestly I'm
i I've yet to really get on this so I
can't quite answer that probably
satisfactory amplicons right okay so
there's going to be some bias there too
yeah and then your sequencing them in
the same way they're all in the Ion
Torrent yes both the data for the second
day in and the fixed dilutions in the
first Dame are going to be sequence on
the same pot one you know following up
on this question because you know my
work does recall and precision on
document retrieval and we have
challenges with you know what is a gold
standard and that's what as you were
talking I was trying to notice think of
this too what what what is what is the
ultimate what do you consider to be the
ultimate truth you know when it comes to
sequencing because you know obviously we
can't look at it you know the DNA itself
and see what the sequence is and then
I'm always from an experimental
standpoint nervous about synthetic data
I mean we we use it for for you know a
number of things but you know you're
always wondering in the back your mind
are there you know is there something
about this data that that maybe you know
skewing us so so how do you really
determine what what truth is in these
things and and if your determination of
what truth is is wrong you know how
robust are your you know algorithms yeah
so I think you know that's a really good
point if we don't get truth right our
algorithms are not going to work really
but i think you know regarding the truth
we've kind of discussed for the the
second game that cytogenetics represents
a pretty good
truth and so that's a totally different
you know method than next generation
sequencing so while we can't assess
truth we can hopefully build enough
confidence that we can you know argue
we've kind of pinned down a good level
of truth that validates the method it's
it's slightly squishy but but it should
you know I think especially you know
when you get to deeper coverage you can
get a very good idea of what that
sequence is and that's something that
will definitely love foraging in the
fixed dilutions and in the second name
data it's just like with judging
documents as relevant there is you know
it's in the eye the beholders so but you
know it's good to think about those
things not that necessarily up obviates
your algorithms but if what dis
potentially biases them in one direction
or another yeah absolutely we're going
to really have to evaluate like what
biases these algorithms may hold and
address and you know any limitations any
other questions
okay well anyway cincin since this is a
thesis proposal defense the the part
after the talks a little more informal
but your your committee will still
discuss with you and determine that
moving on but thank you very much
you